campaigner who took the government to
court and won the right for Parliament
to trigger article 50 is today
announcing that she has reassembled her
legal team Gino Miller says that if
Boris Johnson becomes Prime Minister and
tries to suspend Parliament to deliver
an audio brexit she'll be taking the
government to court once again and Gino
Miller joins me now in the studio a good
morning to explain the rationale behind
this and you had a success you had
success of course with your legal case
compelling the government to legislate
to trigger article 50 what is it about
the power of a prime minister to prolong
Parliament that you see a problem with
well the same legal team that won the
Supreme Court will for me have come
together and we've been talking about
this because the mooting of prorogation
has been sort of we forget who was
actually dominant grab who brought it up
in early June and since then we have
been looking at this and actually we
think that it's beyond the Prime
Minister's powers because parliamentary
sovereignty is actually the sort of
jewel in the constitutional crown and
two bypasses close the doors of
Parliament we feel from the advice in
the case we've looked at that the case
law we've looked at that that would be
beyond a prime ministers powers it would
be an abuse of his powers to close
Parliament to get through or to not get
to her to limit the voice of the
representatives that we all elect
convinced people watching this morning
that this isn't just another remainer
attempt is what breaks it I think in the
environment we're in at the moment
everything is being made into a
political football and this is not this
is very much about defending the central
core of our Constitution which is that
Parliament is sovereign and actually
everybody including especially the Prime
Minister has certain rights so rightly
count including the ability to seem to
go to head to see the Queen and to some
in Parliament they do but in times of
emergency this time to actually do so
for the express purpose of bypassing
Parliament to close the doors of
Parliament and to limit the voice of our
representatives because we are
representative democracy would be beyond
those powers in our view so our legal
say letter that went to the mr. Johnson
on Thursday was to say that if he
Prime Minister that we believe that that
would be beyond his palace and also
relying on the judgment in my case in
2017 where the Supreme Court expressly
said that Parliament could not be
bypassed do you think you've actually
got a real chance of success at the
Supreme Court which is where this will
end up or are you just making as much as
anything else a political point it's
absolutely not a political point because
this case as the first case would
actually not change the outcome of
brexit all it would do is give
Parliament the voice to shape how we
exited or if we did it would be up to
Parliament to decide what it did but the
fact is we cannot shut down Parliament
it is a central pillar of our
Constitution I just wonder if we might
just have a look and we think it's
grateful to you for giving us a look at
the letter that you have sent at 2:00 to
Boris Johnson I wonder if we just take a
look at one line of it here we request
that you undertake not to advise Her
Majesty the Queen's should you become
Prime Minister to parole Parliament
without first providing seven days
notice to our client don't go and see
the Queen if you are Prime Minister and
parole Parliament I mean there will be
people watching this this morning with
who and F do you think you are writing a
letter like that to the man who most
likely will be the next prime minister
well each of us in a democracy each of
us have the right as a citizen to
exercise our power our legitimate
questions of the courts and that's what
I did the first time something to write
a letter to a former foreign secretary
and tell them you know if you become
Prime Minister you know it dies our
client a week in advance if you're going
to go and see the Queen well paying lip
service to the parliamentary democracy
is one thing but you actually have to
actively defend it and that's what this
case and wide legal team when I would be
doing is actively defending
parliamentary sovereignty because as I
said it is the cornerstone of our
Constitution and to abuse that nobody is
above the law you can be a prime
minister you can be whatever your
position we would argue I would argue
that no one is above the law I mean the
one thing that you're not of course
isn't elected representative have you
been speaking to
I mean amongst others so John major
obviously up in the Opera House nobody
even speaking to John Major even
speaking to any Conservative MPs no I've
had no conversations this is as I said
one this question was being mooted or
the propagation question was being
mooted
back in June I wrote an article then and
my legal Tina I have been talking
looking at the judgment in if you like
Miller one the first case and looking at
that judgment and going over it and
seeing that actually we do have a right
to bring this into then not just a
judgment in the case but to fight to say
that the Prime Minister wouldn't have
this power but isn't it fair to say that
you are actually opposed to brexit in
all its forms that this is never new
deal ultimately this is a part another
part of a campaign from a certain part
of the population who voted in a certain
way to try and bring this process to a
grinding halt or at the very least slow
it to the point that people start to say
I some already have do you know what we
just get back to the ordinary business
of politics and making people's lives
better for a while their last statement
in getting back to or people's lives and
making them better is absolutely where
all of us want to be but going back on
your first two questions the first is I
would say that I have never been a fan
of brexit I think any form of Rexha
would diminish us as a country but that
is completely separate that is my
personal view that is completely
different from defending the central
pillar of our Constitution that is about
the black and white letter of the law
and I have not spoken to any
conservatives or anybody else or any
other commentators and if anyone wanted
to adjoin us if we were to go to that
stage we would make absolutely I would
make absolutely certain that it was
about the black and white letter of the
law there is nothing political in that
letter and we have not made this about
brexit it is about giving Parliament's
its voice that is something everybody in
this country should be defend but I
understand that but what we are trying
to do is can a contextualise your
personal views with the actions that
you've been taken I mean do you honestly
believe that if we left the European
Union without a deal that it would be
impossible for the United Kingdom to
recover from that but actually we
couldn't as so many brexit ears say time
and time again we couldn't be in a
better position further down the road
I'm not interested in in what is if it's
going to might be I'm much more
interesting much more interested in the
reality of where we are and the reality
of where we are is that we have a hard
deadline of the 31st of October we have
an extension that was agreed by our
present Prime Minister Mrs May with the
EU which a section 2 of that says there
is no renegotiation of the withdrawal
agreement there is no difference in the
House of Commons it looks like the maths
actually it we've heard
today could have gotten worse because
two members of the Conservative Party
have said they would cross the floor in
in Boris's government so right now the
problem I see is that through
desperation mm-hmm it could be that a
Prime Minister the future Prime Minister
decides to probe Parliament because
there is nowhere else to go
I mean do you expect accept any
responsibility for what we both kind of
characterizes the paralysis that's
existed in government for a while I mean
here initial Sophie and the team have
reported on problems in housing that
haven't been addressed education but
what I'm suggesting is that yourself the
people's vote campaign I'm not part of
the people that's why I made the
distinction okay but you know there's
yourself there's the people's vote
coming we are three years from the vote
and it still hasn't been done
do you accept any responsibility for the
fact that the normal business of
politics is not tightly being carried
out as it should be because of this
focus on trying to get direct it through
in the face of opposition from people
like yourself well I'm not an elected
representative so I'm not in any way
involved in the discussions that happen
in Parliament all I did with my case was
give Parliament its rightful voice and
that's what I'm talking about again but
to have a conversation that's not making
everything into a political football as
I said is where we are as a free society
we are allowed to have opinions and
debates we're allowed to talk about our
opinions without being shut down without
being abused but those are very
different when you look at it from
bringing a legal case the legal case is
distinct from my view or other people's
views and I have to say on you I agree
with everyone who says that we have been
in three years of paralysis and it is an
absolute disgrace that we haven't been
more focused in an outcome and I
personally put that down to the fact and
still have politicians who are lying
about what's going on yes nor answer if
you can if there was if there were snap
election would you stand
no absolutely not general bela thanks
for joining us